wir schauen jetzt in die flutgebiete
denn dort leben menschen die immer noch
vor dem nichts stehen und sie stellen
jetzt schilder auf füttern und anfassen
verboten das sind schilder die wir sonst
nur aus dem zoo kennen uns hier sehen
wir dieses selbst gebastelte schild ein
ganzes dorf wehrt sich nämlich jetzt
gegen ein sehr unangenehmes phänomen
hier es geht um touristen genauer gesagt
um flut touristen warum die anwohner in
mayschoß in rheinland pfalz keine lust
mehr auf besuch haben schauen sie selbst
bei shows hat sat nach der flut kam die
wut die wut über die katastrophen gaffer
das kleine mayschoß in rheinland pfalz
hier rissen die wassermassen das halbe
dorf mit sich danach kamen menschen die
ungefragt das leid der anwohner knipsen
doch jetzt reicht's mit diesem schild
während sich die menschen in mayschoß
gegen die widerlichen gaffer viele
menschen im aartal haben in der
jahrhundertflut vom 14 juli alles
verloren vier einwohner und auch zwei
touristen sterben in den verheerenden
wassermassen häuser und existenzen in
trümmern von rund 400 häusern so 150 von
fluten betroffen 80 sind nicht mehr
bewohnbar nur noch die hälfte der knapp
1000 einwohner lebt im ort ja hier sind
wir im ort beginn ortsteil nach er ist
der am schlimmsten betroffene ortsteil
hier in mayschoß zurzeit wohnt kein
mensch man hier alle sind irgendwo
anders untergekommen dieses haus ist
total zerstört
eines der ältesten gebäude in meisters
die alte mühle das unfassbare stadt mit
anzupacken und zu helfen gaffen die
meisten menschen die nach mainz kommen
nur und machen fotos den bewohnern ist
der kragen geplatzt
sie machen ihrer wut jetzt mit plakaten
luft halten den gaffern damit den
spiegel vor willkommen im zoo
flutopfer fotografieren 10 euro weinende
flutopfer fotografieren 30 euro füttern
verboten
anfassen verboten ich sag mal so jeder
der hier arbeitet ein foto macht ne
schippe in der hand hat ist gern gesehen
soll der medial verbreitet werden dass
noch immer schlimm hier ist aber die
familien die mit ihren kindern
herunterfahren und die fotos machen die
möchte ich nicht gern hier sehen dann
sollen sie auch mit anpacken und nicht
nur im feinen zwirn mit den sauber
geputzten auto vorbeifahren werden wir
abschöpfen sind finde ich ein bisschen
unpassend würden sie bei jedem vergehen
das geld kassieren meisters wäre schnell
saniert
[Musik]